Lindsay Lohan gets candid about her
sobriety family and love life I think
everybody you know has their own path to
life the actress stop by the Wendy
Williams Show on Friday and opened up
about her troubled past I didn't really
know how to have a private life because
I was so young and running around too
much and surrounding myself with people
that probably shouldn't have been around
there weren't there really to support me
there were there so therefore the
lifestyle and so I wouldn't blame anyone
on anything I've done during my life
Lohan's family was in the audience
including her mom Dina and her father
Michael who divorced in 2007 we all have
a great relationship now so tonight as
for her love life the 31 year old says
she's single I don't have a man nobody I
don't
are you single and dating on it need
anyone right now I'm like in work mode I
like it and I really like just being
okay with being okay with me yeah and I
think that it takes a long time in life
I'm 31 years old and when it happens it
will happen
[Music]